I'm here with keys from the track guys
and he's gonna help me not get trolled
on the internet or how to react to it
because I just started doing videos and
obviously people not very nice yeah but
people like you guys yeah well you know
a lot of people refer to me very
affectionately as a SOI boy super kind I
found if you can just insult yourself
worse than they can they really have
nothing left
what's the meanest thing someone's ever
said about it the meanest thing anyone's
said about me I'm sure it was like oh
this dickless loser okay I was called a
fat bitch how could I go lower what
about it loser so I just on myself
yeah hi I'm Keith loser that Benny what
they would actually be inclined to be
like well no you're just you just a fat
loser I mean I gotta be honest as a
woman it's it's tough out there the
words are gonna do is call me some left
is something I mean there'll be much
worse to you so you need to figure out
how to track people's IDs when they
comment you okay and you know threaten
them in person I gotta be honest your
solutions are terrible okay well you
know you asked
you